[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the final trailer for Star Wars Episode
nine the rise of Skywalker debuted on
ESPN during Monday Night Football
this film marks the final chapter in the
Skywalker saga for the Star Wars fans
who've been following the franchise all
along the trailer contained plenty of
clues and hidden references to pick up
on let's take a look first of all the
trailers release date is significant
October 21st 2019 would have been the
63rd birthday of the late Carrie Fisher
who played a Princess Leia in the
franchise until her death in December
2016 according to director JJ Abrams
unseen footage of Fisher as Princess
Leia will be incorporated into the rise
of Skywalker this clip was actually
previewed in the teaser for the final
trailer this ship on the right hand side
resembles the ghost which will look
familiar to fans of the animated series
Star Wars rebels the ghost also appeared
twice in rogue one a Star Wars story
it was captained by hera syndulla who
left her homeworld to start a resistance
movement of her own if this ship is in
fact the ghost that could mean we might
get to see Hera and her crew and rise of
Skywalker in any case the ghost is just
one of a host of Rebel Alliance ships
seen here given this impressive fleet
it's possible the Rebel Alliance is
planning to mount a huge offensive
against the first order and if so this
just might be the most epic space battle
in the history of cinema here kylo
emerges from a wall of water to face Rey
it looks like they'll be fighting each
other on this water planet or are they
actually just training for something
bigger is kylo with the resistance now
the latter seems quite possible
co-writer Chris Terrio suggested in an
interview with Empire that they will
develop the reloj relationship further
for better or for worse in rise of
Skywalker at this point Palpatine's
voice comes in with some ominous words
possibly aimed at kylo and Rey
together
[Music]
is everything going according to
Palpatine's plan does the Sith Lord want
to bring his opponents together so that
he can annihilate them all in one fell
swoop wait but there's a bigger question
how was Palpatine alive anyway he was
supposed to have died in Return of the
Jedi in this shot which shows Rey facing
off with Palpatine for the very first
time it looks like some kind of
machinery is allowing him to move could
it be some kind of cybernetic apparatus
like the spider like robot legs that
Maul used to have whatever it is he must
look pretty scary because the usually
fearless Rey is backing away from him
looking terrified the truth may lie in
the back story behind Darth Sidious as
master Darth Plagueis Darth Plagueis was
rumored to have mastered death until he
was killed by his own apprentice
Palpatine himself yeah it's such a
knowledge of the dark side he could even
keep the ones he cared about from dying
Palpatine claimed that his master taught
him everything he knew if so does that
mean that Palpatine has conquered death
it remains to be seen this ship looks
like it's coming out of the ruins of the
Death Star but it's actually not the
ship that crashed into the second Death
Star at the end of Return of the Jedi
that was a Super Star Destroyer a
different model
it looks like fan-favorite droid c-3po
is getting reprogrammed with the help of
this little creature
a droid smith named Babu Frick who will
be a new character in episode 9
Bobby Frick has the ability to modify or
reprogram pretty much any droid
why is Threepio getting reprogrammed
though and why does he say this
upsetting line are you doing their
appeal taking one last look sir
but my friends one big theory is that
the golden robot an iconic character
who's been around since the beginning of
the franchise must sacrifice himself for
a big mission however it's also possible
he's just undergoing some sort of risky
alteration this is a trailers only
glimpse at Zuri bliss a newcomer on the
scene played by Keri Russell here she's
wearing a helmet standing next to Poe
you can also spot sori in this poster
for the film here's ray embracing
Princess Leia an image likely
constructed using the archival footage
of Carrie Fisher it's worth mentioning
there's a fan theory which holds that
Ray's real mother is in fact Leia here
kylo and Rey are seen on the second
Death Star you can tell the location by
the window of the throne room which is
where Luke and Darth Vader faced off
with Palpatine in Return of the Jedi
that was where the emperor delivered his
famous speech in which he taunted Luke
to seduce him over to the dark side you
like your father
by the trailer closes with the voices of
Luke and Leia speaking these words to
Rey the force will be with you oh this
is a callback to Obi Wan's final words
for Luke at the end of episode 4 a new
hope the force will be with you always
well that's about it did we miss
anything let us know in the comments